Speaker 1: Hey, this you have to see a Republican
official who represents Orange County, California,
named Don Wagner seriously asked during a
hearing whether covid-19 vaccines have a tracking
device in them.
Now, I know we see this on Facebook.
OK, you're wacky.
Uncle might be sharing it, but this is not
your wacky uncle.
This is it.
Well, maybe it's someone's wacky uncle.
This is an actual elected official.
It is Supervisor Don Wagner from Orange County
representing many, many people.
The question came at an Orange County Board
of Supervisors meeting where the prospect
of so-called vaccine passports was being discussed.
Now, we know that Don Wagner himself has been
vaccinated.
He tweeted back on April 3rd with a picture
of himself, one and done with the Johnson
and Johnson vaccine.
Start to finish was forty five minutes.
Great job to everybody.
And thank you to Dr. Chao for administering
my shot, quick and painless.
But here is the same Don Wagner apparently
asking the same Dr. Chao, it seems, who administered
his vaccine about tracking devices.
You have to see it to believe it.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: It's only at the patient's request.
That's correct.
Speaker 2: Does it is there any intention
of tracking folks?
No.
Is there any in the vaccine we heard about
an injection of a tracking device, is is that
being done anywhere?
Speaker 3: In Orange County, I'm sorry,
Speaker 5: I just have to compose myself.
There is not a vaccine with a tracking device
embedded in it that I know of exists in the
world.
Period.
Speaker 1: OK, now I have some news for Don
Wagner that might be shocking to him if he's
worried about being tracked.
He is carrying around a tracking device all
day, every day.
It is his mobile phone, the mobile phone he
carries around in his pocket, probably without
a second thought.
He has a GPS tracker.
Law enforcement, if he were accused of a crime,
could subpoena access to his location depending
on his app permissions.
Apps can get access to his location.
It's in his pocket or sitting on his desk
in front of him as he asks whether the covid
vaccine has a tracking device in it.
This is something I think about every time
these guys bring this up.
The technology piece doesn't exist to do this.
If you look at that syringe, it just doesn't
exist.
But why would you need to do it?
And I know people will say, oh, but what about
the injected microchips into dogs or dogs?
That's a dramatically different size.
And that is not a real time tracker.
That is something you can scan.
If a dog shows up, you can scan it for a microchip.
It will tell you the owner's name.
Completely different thing, not equivalent.
Why go through the trouble?
Of injecting billions of people globally with
a vaccine in order to track them when they
are already carrying around GPS and mobile
phones.
Does he use a debit card or a credit card,
which leaves a breadcrumb trail of where he
has been, an ATM card, which says, where were
you physically withdrawing cash?
Does he wear a mask all day as he walks around
in front of hundreds of CCTV cameras and security
cameras of various kinds?
My instinct is also that there's kind of a
moral hazard at play, which is a funny one
in insurance.
There is this idea that the people insurance
companies most want to insure are the people
who don't really need insurance.
The people that really want insurance and
can't afford not to have it are the risks
that many insurance companies would prefer
not to take on.
My instinct here is that the very people who
believe there is a microchip in the vaccine
are the people doing nothing that would even
be remotely interesting or worthy of being
tracked to begin with.
Why on earth does government want to track?
Like my weird classmate from high school who
posts vaccine tracking Conspiracy's to Facebook,
who works part time at a garden supply store
and never otherwise goes anywhere?
Like who cares where she's going?
Does she thinks she's so important that the
government even cares to know where she is?
Advertisers want to know in order to sell
her stuff, but she's already giving them that
information by using a smartphone posting
about her likes and dislikes on Facebook and
the like.
I by the way, I followed her on Facebook.
It became completely unbearable.
But the point here is, why would the government
even want to track ninety nine point ninety
nine percent of these people to begin with?
It is a sad state of affairs out there.
And this guy represents people.
If you can imagine that.
Let me know if you've had encounters with
these types of find me on Twitter at David
Pakman and tell me tell me how you dealt with
it.
I'm curious to hear we have a great program
for you today.
Glad you're with us.